well the trio live spiritual leader is
being hailed as a hero for saving many
of his congregants rabbi Jeffrey Myers
had just begun his sermon when the
gunman began shooting you can see him on
the front page of yesterday's pittsburgh
post-gazette being escorted out of the
synagogue by police just afterwards now
I spoke with rabbi Myers after
yesterday's interfaith vigil you saved
lives yesterday you were there when the
gunman came in and you grabbed as many
people as you could how are you coping
with that trauma badly I could only save
some the people are in the back of the
sanctuary I could not save what do you
say to the families of those who you
couldn't help I carry that regret with
me and I will the rest of my life that I
could have done more and that I was not
able to do that and that's my burden to
carry can the shooter be forgiven well
big question I just don't know the
wounds are too open to answer that I
have to really think about that can you
really forgive everybody for all evil is
one of those big theological questions
in right now I can't answer it the
rabbi's job now is trying to heal this
community and his congregants now he
will lead funerals for seven of the
victims in the coming days I asked him
how he can help this congregation heal
and he told me quote one hour and one
person at a time is a really emotional
conversation that I had with him and so
many others here yesterday